[Music]
great white sharks have been a big draw
to south africa nature lovers for
decades
but now their numbers are in steep
decline sightings of this
deadly predator off the country's
western cape have been dropping
rapidly for the past five years deborah
potter went to see
with a group of researchers who urgently
are trying to figure out why the ocean
is so quiet
[Music]
it's a bumpy ride from khan spy as we
head off with renowned
shark expert sara andriati
this was once the shark capital of the
world
but now the apex predator which has
survived over 400 million years
is in deep trouble four years ago you'd
see between
five to twenty great white sharks a day
during peak season
now you'd be lucky to see that many in
an entire year
oh he caught us by surprise this trip
just happened to be
one of those lucky days so the deadly
silence that we've seen
no great white sharks around us is
actually an alarm
yeah is is sad also the disappearance of
such a
large predator there you go that was
excellent
timing what are we what happened that's
a broad winner
this is the first white shark andriyati
has seen in over two years
getting a sample is crucial not so easy
when your subject
keeps outwitting you with its mercurial
movement
but after several attempts including a
thorough soaking there's calls
for celebration
[Music]
oh yes this time without a sample
what does it mean to get a sample from
the great white so it could give an
indication of whether we have new sharks
coming in the bay
a new shark coming in the bed so where
have
all the other sharks gone
many scientists believe long line
fishing is one of the main culprits
it legally targets smaller shark species
exported to australia for fish and chips
the problem
explains marine biologist mary rollinson
is this is also the shark's food
so we are depleting their food resources
and if you deplete the food resources it
creates greater competition between
individuals which makes it more
difficult for each individual white
shark to survive
then there's the problem of fishermen
inadvertently catching
sharks in other words you put down a big
net and you're trying to catch
hake but instead you catch
sharks and chimera and rays so it's kind
of collateral there is collateral damage
some researchers blame the disappearance
of the great whites on another predator
killer orca whales saying they've chased
the shark population away
but andriyati is not buying this orcas
and great whites have lived within close
proximity in this area before
with no problems my bigger fear is that
while we are arguing whether they move
or whether they're being killed off
we lose the few that are still left
over 100 miles away in another hot spot
false bay the shark population has also
declined
dramatically seferina gelderblum has
watched the numbers dwindle first
hand for 12 years he's been a shark
spotter
sounding a warning when they swim
dangerously close to surfers
but that siren has been silent for a
long time now
it does concern me because i mean they
they on top of the food chamber so
they keep the seals intact so they feed
on the
the sick and injured so they just keep
it balanced so
without the shark circling the bay
there's been a proliferation of seals
more seals means more fish are being
eaten affecting
the delicate ecosystem of the ocean an
ocean
we depend on for oxygen if you don't
have those top predators there keeping
everything in balance and in check
unfortunately
our oceans will eventually die so
protecting the oceans is protecting
ourselves
great whites are often incorrectly
portrayed as bloodthirsty killers
preying on humans
but it turns out we could well be their
biggest threat
for cbs this morning saturday deborah
padda
hunts by you know a lot about this
galore
the lions of the ocean the great balance
keepers yeah
if that's out of whack then everything
else is on the water but how incredible
that moment in the picture i know
she hadn't seen a white shark in two
years and it showed up during the
interview he's like
you talking to me talking about me i'm
here